Ось ця головна.
Вона всіх ганяє постійною.
Ото люди заходять... Вона не небезпечна.
Б'ється просто мордою  — і все.
До речі, свиня  — розумна тварина.
Люди думають, що вони дурні. Ні, ніфіга.
Свині дуже розумні.
Характер у них тільки важкий свинячий.
[сміється]
Особисто я відчув себе українцем у Португалії.
Я приїхав... Он як людям розповідаю:
я у 2008 році повернувся, з 2001 року я там був.
Людям розказував,
що ми там реально патріоти.
А ви тут тільки «бла-бла».
Ви не розумієте, що таке Батьківщина,
бо ми там побули і повернулися.
Ми більше розуміємо.
Я не знаю, маю я рацію чи ні,
але у мене таке почуття.
У мене там також і прапор український
висів, і рушнички.
Усе це мати вислала.
Я попросив, щоб воно було.
І завжди  у мене там все було.
Уся наша сільвага. А потім.... ви знаєте.
Потім  у 2012 у нас був Євро дуже цікавий.
Ми, коли на машину поставили
український прапор,
їхали, усі сигналили, кричали, махали,
люди так раділи.
Це ж 2012 рік? Я не помиляюся? 2012!
І наприкінці 2013 такий крутий розворот.
Торгував оптом ковбасами ще у Донецьку.
Війна. Поїхали. Бізнес там розікрали.
Виїхали. Приїхали сюди.
Ця хата була у нас вже давно.
Вивезли, що могли.
Потім пішов я добровольцем
через військомат в армію.
Відслужив у 54 бригаді. 7 квітня 2016 повернувся.
От і почали ми...
З цього.
Тобто хата була.
Це вже бачте застаріло все.
Це треба міняти,
але зараз у нас гроші не торгові,
а фермерські.
Трохи інше. Розуміте?
[сміється]
А це ще «священна корова».
Залишки. Була розкіш.
[сміється]
Кози вдень поки тут.
А сьогодні якраз отримав електропастух.
Будемо виводити туди.
Качки теж живуть самі по собі.
Харчуються в основному мухами,
какашками козячими — екологічно чисто.
У самоті тут живе на літній дачі Султан.
Султан, іди покажися.
Його всі люблять знімати. Він у нас незвичайний:
морда нубійська.
Саме головне те, що ми здобули за гроші «Куркуля»
[«Український донецький куркуль»], — оця  сироварня.
Заходить сюди молоко.
Отут розводяться ферменти.
Тут воно у котлі робиться.
Це бринза сьогодні зроблена.
Це завтра вона на базар поїде.
Дуже унікальна програма в Україні є.
Я впевнений, що в решті областів такої нема.
Програма у чому полягає:
пишеш бізнес план, здаєш його,
фінансується (коли я ще отримував)
50% від місцевого бюджету, 50% від області.
Ми продаємо в деяких крамницях у Слов'янську,
Костянтинівці,  Краматорську,
у Facebook дуже активно.
Зараз осінь. Зима попереду.
Це дуже активні продажі ідуть.
[Звук мобільного телефону]
Улітку — так-сяк: через «Нову пошту»
не дуже класно відсилати.
Вибачте. Алло.
Зіта-Гіта, народила?
— Дівчинка чи хлопчик?
— [російською] Я не можу зрозуміти.
Та зараз, давай. Оп.
Дівчина.
У цьому році стільки хлопчиків. Слабенько.
Та нормально, витримаю.
Вона не повинна була жити. І бач, вижила.
А це просто красень. Шкода, що хлопчик.
Дуже багато породи взяв нубійської.
Ось ця порода називається угорська мангалиця.
Чим вона унікальна?
По-перше, це родич іберійських свиней, чорних.
Але іберійські свині в нас
не можуть жити: дуже холодно.
Угорська мангалиця дуже добре живе,
і ось, з місячного віку вони живуть отут.
Тільки назиму багато стелимо соломи  —
і все вперед.
Не потрібен ні сарай, нічого.
Навіть для них сарай некорисний.
Здорова голова.
У Львові ходив на наші мітинги, проукраїнські.
Це вже був березень.
У квітні вже останні були.
Після бою в [Донецькому] аеропорту...
26 травня він відбувся.
Ми його пережили у центрі міста.
А 3 червня ми вже виїхали.
Уже не повернулися жодного разу.
У нас там є квартири і будинки.
Будинок і дві квартири.
У мене є ідея: ми там ще три гектари беремо.
Був тесть, є жінка.
Ще по півтора гектара нам передбачено —
ми їх оформимо.
А якщо далі можна буде взяти, то можна
свиней повністю перевести туди на природу,
навіть зробити екскурсію.
Для багатьох людей, які в місці живуть,
що побачити фазана, що таку качку —
одне й те саме.
Вони дуже дивуються.
А таких свиней, то взагалі просто...
Навіть селяни, які бачили звичайних свиней,
побачили таких свиней кажуть:
«Ой, а що ж це таке!».
Розумієте?
Це для людей цікаво.
Я по життю такий:
у яку посудину налили, там і тримаюся.
Мені нескладно.
Після звільнення Донецька
ми вже не поїдемо туди жити.
Ми ж це не повеземо і не кинемо.
[сміється]